just when we thought the consensus was
to leave Lucas wounded and stranded from
making Star Wars movies it seems some
fans have pulled a 180 flip and are
punching it right back to bespin JJ
Abrams may have turned Star Wars The
Force awakens into one of the biggest
films ever made but some fans are keen
to see franchise creator George Lucas
return to the director's chair one last
time an online petition has been created
calling for Lucas to direct Star Wars
Episode nine Yuri Luiz from Brazil is
hoping to persuade bosses at Lucasfilm
to replace Jurassic world director Colin
Trevorrow with Lucas for the final part
of the new trilogy which is due in 2019
we have no problem with Colin Trevorrow
but he's not the right guy to direct
Star Wars Episode nine Louie's rights on
the change.org page George Lucas as
director of episode 9 would be the
perfect way to end this new trilogy and
make an epic farewell between the father
of Star Wars and the whole universe of
the galaxy far far away at the time of
this video the petition has attracted
6401 signatures in 2012 Lucasfilm was
sold to Disney who paid around four
billion for the company the studio's
subsequently announced that they would
deliver a new Star Wars movie every year
interspersing the ongoing saga with
one-off films focusing on different
characters in the Star Wars universe the
first of these gareth edwards rogue one
will open in december this year just
last December lucas caused some
controversy by suggesting that he wasn't
exactly a fan of the direction that star
wars the force awakens has taken disney
wanted to do a retro movie
he told interviewer Charlie Rose I don't
like that every movie I worked very hard
to make completely different different
planets different spaceships to make it
new he also described Disney as white
slavers Disney subsequently clarify
these comments telling USA Today Disney
is doing an incredible job taking care
of and expanding the franchise I rarely
go out with statements to clarify my
feelings but I feel it is important to
make it clear that I am thrilled that
Disney has the franchise and is moving
it in such exciting directions in film
television and the parks so what do you
think - the master behind the franchise
come back for episode 9
or should the series move on and leave
behind the chosen one you love the
chosen one Anakin it was said that you
in the store this is not join them
violence in a fault